Hi everyone.
My name is Yusei Kikuchi of the Seattle Mariners.
I am very happy to be here.
Today is a very special day for my family and I.
Thank you for my family and amazing wife, Rumi, my friends, my high school coach,...
...and my mentor, Mr. Sasaki for  supporting me everyday.
Playing in the big league has been a dream of mine...
...since I was 15 years old.
Thank you, Seibu Lions for letting me go on and live my dream.
Mariners ownership and Mr. Dipoto and Mr. Servais...
...thank you for this new journey.
And to my new teammates, I can't wait to meet you guys soon.
Thank you.
I feel this team really needed me the most.
And I feel chemistry between us.
Ah, yeah.
I don't know the details yet but I want to practice hard and adjust myself.
And I want to enjoy every single thing.
My strong points is fastball and slider.
And yeah.
I watched Wikipedia...
...and I hear there are enthusiastic fans here in Seattle.
And it is a beautiful city.